hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today I'm gonna be
making a knife out of this farriers rasp
and as a little added bonus we're gonna
be giving away this 70 dollar brand new
the wall angle grinder to one of you
guys so stay tuned watch the video and
at the end I'm going to show you how you
can win this angle grinder
[Music]
well today I'm gonna be making a
frontiersman knife that's loosely based
off of the Kephart knifes from 1906 they
were a knife sold to frontiersman for
skinning and hunting and cooking and
just kind of a good all-purpose hunting
and camping knife and I'm gonna use this
old farriers rasp to do it farriers rasp
Saar made of generally pretty good
quality steel and they're roughly the
shape of the knife I want anyway so it's
not gonna require a lot of effort to get
the profile right making knives is
probably one of the easiest types of
tools to make and if you're looking to
get into this sort of hobby this is a
great project for you
do not let professional knife makers
intimidate you okay you don't need a lot
of fancy equipment you don't need to use
the ideal of materials you can make a
really awesome functional knife with
very minimal materials and tools see if
we can't make something fund out of this
let's see what do we want okay so I drew
out the outline of the knife with this
sharpie on the back of the farriers rasp
but if you don't feel comfortable doing
that freehand or if you want a more
exact profile draw what you want on
paper and tape it to the blade or even
print off a full sized picture of the
knife you want to make and just tape it
to the blade and then work around it
[Music]
[Applause]
all right there we go it doesn't look
too bad fits in the hand well all we got
to do now is put an edge on it polish it
a little bit we're ready to go now I've
polished up the handle and it looks
freakin amazing that texture from the
rasp is really cool but if I grind it
down then I can't do yes check that out
so I need to decide what I want it to
look awesome or work awesome so I got a
bucket of vinegar here sit in here and
soak em well I took a little lunch break
and when I came back outside it started
snowing on us so we're gonna go under
the front porch here so we can keep
working on this project without get my
tools all wet
guys I love my angle grinder and you can
do almost this entire project with just
an angle grinder but the trickiest part
is the bevel of the blade getting that
exactly right freehand with an angle
grinder is really difficult so one of
these these numbers these belt Sanders
really helps it allows you to get a more
precise angle on the bevel more
consistent angle on the bevel just makes
it look a lot better so this runs this
is a low-end one this robee makes it
$119 brand new so for about a hundred 19
bucks if you really want to up your game
this is the next tool to buy but if you
can't afford this don't be afraid to use
that angle grinder even if the edge
doesn't come out perfect still will work
you know silicosis
[Applause]
all right we got the knife looking good
now let's make the handle I've got this
beautiful piece of morado which is an
exotic hardwood that looks amazing so
I'm gonna take a piece and chop it up
and make some blanks for the handle now
that's gonna make a cool handle right
there guys you don't need fancy tools to
do this I just drilled three holes
through this knife using a corded hand
drill and a $5 box set of drill bits I
think I got this one of those sale bins
at Lowe's and just started with an
8-inch then went up to 960 fours 5/32
3/16 and then quarter-inch and just by
stepping it up slowly I was able to
drill very quickly three holes with some
pretty cheap drill bits
now normally what you do is drill a hole
and then put a pin in it then drill
another hole and put a pin in it and
drill a hole to keep it from sliding
around on you because if it slides in
the middle of drilling it was completely
ruin the blank however because this has
the rasp texture on it on both sides it
really locks into place it doesn't slide
around on me so I can kind of do a
little bit faster and cheat a little bit
well there we go nice and straight nice
and even so take the two polished ends
put them together if you don't see any
gaps then you're good to go
[Music]
oh this file takes the poxy just gobbles
it up okay got it all blocked up we'll
let it cure for about an hour or so and
then we'll go for it
well there we go the epoxy is dried for
about a day and a half now and now I
need to start cutting off all the excess
and shaping up the handle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright let this dry overnight and it is
looking good nice form to it all right
let's see how it cuts all right let's
take a look at her man that handle
turned out great yeah Oh a nice edge on
there there we go nice looking knife
nice looking she works real well
yeah I'm really pleased with how this
turned out okay guys let me show you a
feature about this knife that I really
love okay it's nice and wet outside
everything so you want to build a fire
yeah okay
there we go
the old fire going alright guys I told
you I would be giving away the $70
Dewalt angle grinder to one of you guys
and I'm gonna do just that if you want
to win this angle grinder all you have
to do is three things first make sure
you're subscribed to the outdoor boys
YouTube channel also leave a comment
telling me what your favorite outdoor
boys video is okay it can be any of our
70 something videos we've uploaded tell
us which one's your favorite and third
share this video on any social media
platform or any website that includes
YouTube Facebook Instagram snapchat or
you can go on a forum or whatever I'm
gonna pick the winning comment one week
from today but I hope you guys enjoyed
this video hope you learn something new
and I hope you guys get out there and
try making knives and doing fun projects
like this at home thanks for watching
and don't forget to click subscribe
thanks for watching we hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you'd like to see
more great videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
Subscribe we put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video